the champion has arrived what's going on
Kofi Kingston oh my god that is a it's
waiting snake waiting if you only have
one belt do they give you one to carry
around with you tell them Sam I don't
want to tell them it's a championship
title you wear a belt around your pants
yeah yeah that holds your pants up
this here is a title it's a big
difference I don't fit in your belt loop
sir right okay
is there one title or one day there's
several this one is the the traveling
black light goes with me you know goes
wherever I go oh yes you do have to
carry it everywhere I do yes has the
magic of being WWE Champion worn off and
now it's like I can't believe I have to
carry this 15 pounds it is a big problem
like if I'm being honest like I was kind
of looking forward to carrying Daniel
Bryan's like you know eco-friendly title
I'm like you know what it's gonna be
real light in the suitcase this is great
Daniel Bryan played a character that is
he was like a nature guy yeah so he made
a he won the WWE Championship and he
remade the title to assist all
sustainable material I was like man you
know he's onto something yeah again like
the first world problems like all my
belts is too heavy in my bag I gotta go
through security uh lug that around I do
yeah and you can't check it no you'd be
a fool oh I bet it'll go missing yo yeah
yeah you know goes in the carry-on oh I
always I always take it with me
everywhere I go okay yeah so you are you
guys you guys you're you got to be
excited the last I don't know if was the
last time I saw you in Madison Square
Garden but you like you went to Madison
Square Garden ten years ago yeah and
almost had a moment where like you were
gonna achieve the levels of success that
you've achieved now we all thought you
were that kind of vanished right after
Madison Square Garden right what
happened you went away no so a dastardly
man by the name of Randy Orton so he and
I were having this rivalry back and
forth and like Sam was saying ended up
like an MSG
me putting him through a table and one
for my career like iconic moment you
know what I mean a highlight of my
career and you know the way things go
when you have these moments you kind of
keep on climbing the ladder and you go
you know to becoming the WBA champion
and Brandi didn't like me so I don't
this is like not like a storyline thing
you know real he didn't like this is for
real like he you know didn't want me to
get to this point so at the time randy
was on top so he kind of went to a
couple of people and you know you know
expressed his dismay for me and then
before you knew it I was kind of going
back down and I've had like a decent
career you know I've done a lot of great
things but never quite got here until
WrestleMania this man why didn't he like
you I don't know I think I'm a likable
guy I don't know I don't know what it
was man um you know we had a match where
he ended up calling me stupid a lot you
know in the match and and so again this
is like not stories I like he's not he's
not saying to you right right so so and
I'm and I'm saying like you know it's
it's a fine line that we walk like
between like what's real and what's not
and even over the years I've been asked
about this I'm like oh well you know in
the storyline like we didn't like each
other but now that it's out in the open
you know I'm very open about it like he
had a lot to do with why I it took me so
long to get here you know cuz uh a lot
of things have to go right for you to
become WBA champion you have to be in
the right place at the right time you
know have a lot of great moments and
then be in the good graces of the higher
ups who were making the decisions and he
took me out of those good graces so
you'd be doing something he just said
what are you doing stupid like we're
only you could hear it yeah whoa but
everybody heard it because it was you
know it was in the ring you know so so
this is one of the things that I get
replayed on my Twitter all the time like
up until this this whole rivalry is that
I remember when Randy called you stupid
II quote kill your push they call it you
know that's the the insider term is the
push you know when you're getting the
the push to be in the main event and and
that is what happened you know so it's
it's kind of poetic that we're here at
this point now I know ever since I won
the WB championship this was always the
rivalry that I wanted because I feel
like it's important especially in life
we all have people who have tried to
hold you down and prevent you from
getting to where you want to be and you
know for me to look somebody in the face
and say you were wrong about me all
these years man because now here I am
and here you are trying to get what I
have you know it's very poetic and full
circle and that took place at Madison
Square Garden the last time that WWE was
televised in Madison Square Garden here
10 years ago and now we're going to be
on the cusp of doing it again
oh you're messing them again yes we're
deep we're in the thick of it right now
you know without with our rivalry so uh
now see I was thinking about that a lot
because now it is my storyline right
like now you are actually having matches
and part of this rivalry how do you look
at a person like in the face you're
talking about this real life stuff that
people are aware of so it's part of a
storyline now how do you not just look
at him and go like I don't want to
cooperate with you right now I want to
kill you yeah youyou took food off my
table right on my family's tip and in
the same vein like now that's kind of
where we're at like businesses business
you know you come to work and you
probably have a bunch of people you
don't want to see and you don't want to
work with everybody people go to school
you don't want to see certain people you
have certain teachers you like certain
teachers you don't like but you know at
the end of the day like it's my job to
go out there and perform but there is
that element of reality behind us and I
think the best story lines always hinge
on that little bit of reality that
that's also going on you know you look
at Ed's back in the day and in that oh
my god
you know what I'm saying so there's just
like it's it's cool to be in that spot
you know to be have been around so long
that the old stuff that you did is still
significant to this day so have you said
to him like what the [ __ ] were you doing
like why did you do that to me behind
the scenes I mean we don't we don't talk
like that you know what I'm saying but
um and we've never had that conversation
but I mean it is what it is I don't
really it doesn't it at this point to me
like it doesn't matter because I've
overcome it you know what I'm saying so
for me to look back and wonder why like
I don't why the Y doesn't really matter
to me what matters to me is to be able
to stand over him holding the title you
know and and get that that shot because
it's just
a picture's worth a thousand words you
know it's that crazy about athletes that
they have this tunnel vision that like I
don't think you or I can understand like
if this this tunnel vision of like well
there's a one-goal here there's a
mission and regardless of everything
else going on you just stick to it you
go forward and if you're doing if you're
succeeding then everything's going right
like I think you or I Jim would just be
sitting there obsessing over the fact
that somebody was like politicking and
being shitty this is the first I'm
hearing of this uh-huh and it's annoying
we do like we evoke emotion as WWE
Superstars and storytellers like that's
like I said man the best storylines
always have a bit of reality involved in
them so he brought awesome be a part of
that Kofi brought up edge of Matt Hardy
I don't know if you're familiar with
that storyline from a year a few years
ago I am but that all I'll explain it to
you as for the sake of the audience but
like edge legit had an affair with Matt
Hardy's legit girlfriend who was a
performer on the show like they were all
performers on the show but Matt Hardy
was away with an injury and she started
sleeping with edge in real life and it
became a thing that the internet kind of
became aware of how'd they get caught
I think voicemails or texts or something
like that one of the old like classic
way is do it blubber your beeper but
because everybody knew on the internet
they were like alright let's make a
storyline out of it and they had them
like actually now do they ever make up
for real no idea I don't see I have no
idea I mean I know both of them very
well and they're both moved out and good
places in their lives yeah what I'm
saying edge has an amazing families with
Beth Phoenix as his wife and she's an
amazing person they have amazing kids
same thing Matt Matt Matt Hardy's him
and his wife and his kids are awesome
too so I mean like you know I suppose
which one the one yeah who is the
girlfriend she does not not with us
anyway I don't know if I don't think
you've wrestled she's around but yeah
she's doing stuff she's in a band you
know so we've got a well informed
wrestling question does the girl still
rest
[Laughter]
not answer for you neither one of us
thought that was the question that was
going to come have you have you figured
out the sneaker hookup yet cuz I know
you I could I could tell you for working
on this you wrestle in sneakers I told
somebody so coffee he's wrestles in like
popular and new sneakers and I told
somebody who just doesn't know anything
about wrestling but knows a lot about
sneakers I was like a cofee was wearing
the fear of gods which are these new
sneakers new guys
you wrestle they know you're comfortable
they look cool they look cool and
they're actually not bad they're pretty
lightweight the fear of God ones and uh
I paint a lot more than you know then
the retail actually was so that part
like like I still the the sneaker head
of me is like why am I wearing these I'm
like no no it's okay it's okay it's it's
a write-off trying to just yeah yeah
yeah but um no I I enjoy sneaker sneaker
culture quite a bit man as you know I
mean even right now I've got these uh
the 50th anniversary of one consortium
and and nice kicks a little
collaboration tie-dye on the uppers you
know what I'm saying so I've become more
and more of a sneaker head especially
being able to wear sneakers in the ring
there was a point in time and we joke
about this we're so bill demott used to
be our trainer down in Deep South in
Atlanta and he would require all of his
students to wear boots like actual
wrestling boots and my athleticism went
down by like 75% like really yeah man I
can't wrestle in Boots man like my house
sliding all over the place like they
were heavy on my feet I just felt like
an oaf you know Kofi the oaf you know
could have been my moniker but uh
luckily I could wear sneakers out there
cuz I mean you know you know we play
pick-up basketball growing up and you
did everything in sneakers why wouldn't
you wrestling sneaker what's the most
you ever spent on a pair of sneakers
whoo well private the fear gods that I'm
wearing right now
um little over $1,000
yeah I mean I get it I've had a habit
sore thing for you oh yeah you also
probably can't like search online for
the best price and but like you need
them right now you got to go to the
store it's gonna be the highest price
you're gonna find it's crazy and then so
actually the fear of guys that I wore
before the orange ones
um I so me woods and II figured out we
were gonna be on the pay-per-view
together so like oh we should get new
outfits and you know I asked them if
they wanted to do like the green ones
the green or the Orion I said I'm both
shoes I'm like which ones you want to
like Center these are color scheme
around they pick the orange one so I was
like okay so I ordered that and it ended
up being like pretty pricey from stock X
and stock X is a place where you can
order cool sneakers and then you ship
them to the headquarters they verify
them and then they ship them to you so
it's an extra long process for the
delivery I didn't realize that it was
gonna take longer to get to me
it was gonna get to me after the
pay-per-view so I had them already
ordered oh oh no so then I went on to
like flight Club calm yeah ordered
another pair I expensive how to get like
the rush delivery yeah so then I I mean
I ended up like selling them back for a
little bit less than I paid for them but
still like it was it was stressful you
show them back to to where the stock XO
you buy and sell sneakers on stock X
yeah that's great
what you got away with being like now
that stock did you think to yourself
like I could probably find a sneaker
head and a wrestling fan
that's like these are just pass him off
as rings so that's the other thing is
like I keep all my sneakers man like I
have you single pair of sneakers that
I've ever worn in like bins in my house
it's bad weight and everyone you've worn
where you're working when I've worked
yeah yeah yeah so and then even yeah
it's it's a problem you know the problem
the most satisfying sneaker moment I
don't care about sneakers at all was our
friend rich Voss is a person who really
there's something wrong with him work
the way he communicates was in the
Comedy Cellar somebody came up with new
sneakers but they had like really nice
ones they were so proud of him and he's
like those are [ __ ] ugly somebody try
to justify how nice their news and then
try to qualify but no these are the No
oh good by the way rich boss is our he's
been in comedy for 30 years I was going
to say 70 30 years so we convinced Jim
to do his one of his comedy specials a
couple years ago in fakies he's like
fakies from Amazon like yeah but it just
looked like you were in black shoes yeah
I'm special you just more for like us
sir and the radio fans like knowing like
these are yeah but when you looked at
him in person you could really tell they
were fake
yeah and rich considers himself a
sneaker aficionado even though he's now
some of these fakes you can't tell men
like these when Z came in an unmarked
boxing ring on them in absorb it was a
plain cardboard box so Jim ordered like
how many pairs I ordered like five pairs
because I have weird feet so I didn't
know what size would fit and I was
shooting some so I just get the sizes
one of them will fit and they're $20 but
we have rich on the air and we were like
rich like jim has a whole bunch of extra
ease ease and they're the black ones
they go for a lot of money and he goes
you got him Jim's like yeah I never warm
I don't know what they are if you want
him take him you could try to sell him
you gotta give me a you split split the
money if you can sell them we actually
got him to go to a sneaker store no $20
feces from him as hell oh my god he
walks into the sneaker store he's a man
of a certain don't May 61 years old he's
got all his like rings on and everything
and he goes like yeah how much can I get
for these and the guy literally opens a
box doesn't even pull them out because
these are fake that's great but people
haven't like reached out to you yet and
been like why don't we just send you
free sneakers or is it because you have
specific tastes I don't like I don't I
don't mind paying for them you know what
I'm saying I enjoy like the thrill of
the chase you know and and thinking
about us thinking that I want and then
like having to go through the whole
process of like you know okay
do I want to clash with this outfit or
do I want to
to coordinate perfectly and then I like
that the main thing is that like I need
it when I need it so I can't like haggle
with people like ok well I'll give you
this I'll give you a you know I I just I
don't have it in your an impulse buyer I
gotta have it when I want it when I want
it the other thing about stock acts this
got my wife like furious one year
because she also didn't realize the
system like it's a website it's a eBay
for sneakers but it's super verified so
you know you're not getting fixed
there's so many fakes out there but like
Kofi said you they send it to the
warehouse they verify the sneakers then
they send it to you so it takes like two
weeks instead of five days so they know
that you're not getting crap but lots of
times when they verify it at the
warehouse they're like these are fake
and you don't get anything you get your
money back
right but like Jess tried to get me some
sneakers and she was losing your mind
because right before Christmas that
really these are fake and there goes the
gift like it's just like there's nothing
right and she had to go and find the
sneaker is it one of these other spots
hey like two times as much I just kept
the fakes grab my purses on going the
same I know it's it's crazy wouldn't
kick patio for him barely even see mine
you know the thing and it's just funny
too is that uh so back in the day we
would always get clown for wearing like
different brands right like so if you
were like Nike pants with Adidas shoes
perpetrating you couldn't do it so like
in my mind so to this day it's like it's
hard to do that but like right now I'm
wearing this Nike jumpsuit and these
Adidas sneakers because I love the
sneaker so much I didn't even realize a
bit like I was clashing until I walked
out the door like I don't care oh yes
it's like so liberating you know yeah
man you got into that place yeah I'm not
quite there where I can wear the fakes
just yet yeah you know but great I said
man you can't tell like some of them are
so well done they're made by the same
companies and factories and you know
overseas and where the fakes if they
were spelled wrong like not only are you
the WWE Champion so you're like the top
of the heap but you're also like
cementing yourself and trying to I think
as the number one sneaker guy in WWE so
if you get caught and you will get
caught yeah
people I mean their Instagram accounts
clone dedicated you'll be close to
celebrities wearing fake sneak really oh
oh my the best you show me your own
photos to that but like you can't like
especially now you're in a position can
you imagine going to the ring and like
you know people check like the Jordan
logo is like not quite right no I know
look at that toe box no we'll get caught
and I remember in fourth grade a horror
story uh my parents would always only by
me sneakers from Payless you know and I
got a pair of sneakers that looked like
the Larry Johnson's that came out you
know the LJ's and I went the first day
of school and I'm when everyone's like
oh you got the LJ's I'm like oh yeah
yeah yeah
and then like at lunchtime they looked a
little closer and realized they were
what we call Bobo's you know fakes yeah
and then I'll just clown the whole day
so I'm still like traumatized that was
fourth grade never get over there thirty
years ago do you watch Atlanta a little
bit a little bit wasn't he a really big
into it there's literally an episode
about like two two kids
Donald lovers character they go back in
time like fourth grade oh yeah and he
and another kid in class show up in
matching FUBU shirts oh nice but the
threading isn't quite right on one of
them so they spend the whole day and
both of them are panic trying to figure
out because it's over isn't it funny the
thread is how you figure out a lot of
these yeah sweatshirts but it's like who
cares I I know I guess they really I
wouldn't give a [ __ ] and you shouldn't
give you shouldn't care right like you
really sit in but I don't know man we're
brainwash I prefer it fake I mean every
time I girls ever had an orgasm you
think I bought it are you are you a
little OCD with with I mean yeah yeah
yes no yes and no I mean it depends on
what it is there are some stickers that
are like I just won't wear like I have a
pair of Adidas
nmd masterminds that I got so I I rarely
only up until recently have I paid like
top dollar for sneakers I refuse to do
it like back in the day and these ones
used to go for so much and then we ended
up doing a an episode of like sneaker
shopping at flight club that was paid
for by the company but you can get
whatever shoes you want I was like oh
how about these now I have those
masterminds but I've to this day I've
never worn them and it's been like three
years you just play them I just yeah no
I just have about having my closet yeah
so they're not they're not even like
really displayed they're like I know
yeah there's a bus or but they're there
and I just can't like I don't know I
have to find the black proper occasion
to wear them a situation where I know
what my day is gonna be where I'm not
gonna be on like say a baseball field
right there's like that you know orange
dirt that's gonna ruin my sneakers I
have to like plan it all out so but that
people are gonna see you doing so you're
also not just sitting around the house
right yeah like people have to see it
but under the right conditions exactly
it has to be just right man it has to be
just right liking is weird I can I
collect other types of things it really
is just like hoarding but like a
thousand years advanced mentally yeah
like I I'm I have to double up every
pair of sneakers have to yeah I have to
have a second printer like it used to
just be like you know what
first it was like I'm never gonna do
that then it was like let me just get to
the really nice ones and now literally
every single pair like I got I got a
pair that were way tougher to get than I
think people thought it would be like
two weeks ago
and I got it off the app I got him for
retail and everything and I've seen
people wearing it I'm like these are
amazing and I can't wear them because I
couldn't find my second pair I drove all
around my neighborhood looking for like
you know you have to go at the right
time hoping that people don't pick up
the ones that they want and they're
raffles nobody had them so now they're
just sitting there and I'm going like I
want to wear them but I don't have the
second pair so I can't bring them out go
back and get them I mean these are all
get aboard a thing what if you can't but
what if it's not a gettable thing right
and don't have it these ones I got off
the app and that's my other rule is that
if I have to like go online to get
the second pair because I can a hundred
thousand ten thousand percent verify
these ones are legit because I got them
off the app there's no more legit shoe
in the world I'm gonna wear the other
pair not the one that I got the one I
got off the app has to sit there and
wait till I figure out what to do a
second pair and it doesn't even bring
joy I know it like your stuff is just in
the closet I'm like what the [ __ ] am i
doing and why even like especially with
sneakers to like wearing them around
like it's not fun because I don't want
anyone to step on my snake you know so
it was a Puma came out with the walking
dead sneakers and they actually had like
dirt scuffs marks on them you know like
painted on yeah not like this is the
greatest thing in the world worried
about anything I can like scuff them up
like it's supposed to look like this so
yeah it's a dangerous game yeah but wait
to get to the place where you're like
you have it now my scuff mark yeah you
scoffs that's not the right that's not
the original scuff mark and you're
driving yourself crazy
it's weird I mean you get it from all
your life other stuff yeah like these
sneakers I've had for probably a year
year and a half like I have a hard time
flying and I love the fact that I don't
give a [ __ ] about sneakers that's
expensive
I watch him going crazy on the ass just
funny to me like I hope you don't get
them just not with that with other stuff
right right totally dangerous game bro
when you get to a place right like I
feel like out of out of everybody really
you've probably had the best post
WrestleMania season in WWE because the
thing like about Kofi is that you won
the WWE Championship at WrestleMania but
like we were talking about like you're a
guy who spent years in this kind of
position in WWE of well people loved him
and he's amazing yeah he's not ever
gonna be the WWE Champion like this is
not a guy who's ever gonna be in the
main event and then fan support picked
up and it was just a moment and the
timing and you got your moment other
people have got in that moment and they
get the moment and more often than not
those moments end up being like just
those moments right like it's not a
long thing it's just like this moment is
amazing and then we end up moving on to
the next thing I feel like for you the
momentum hasn't died down at all you
know what I mean you're still the
champion months later do you feel that
and how do how do you gauge success in
Pro Wrestling um for me like you said
things happen so fast I mean the first
example that came in my mind was Zack
Ryder at WrestleMania winning the
Intercontinental Championship yeah I
know his dad was in the ring is such a
beautiful moment and then less than 24
hours later losing it you know so in the
back of my mind I was like man this was
a great moment like I they're gonna do
me like this you know am I gonna lose
the next day are we just gonna have the
moment and then all of a sudden we
didn't you know that amazing know that
you don't know yeah like [ __ ] now you
enjoying the moment your kids are in the
ring with you and you know as a
performer you're like it could just be
this moment it could just be tonight and
you enjoy it for what it is you know
what I'm saying because like you were
saying it's been a lifelong goal and
dream for me to be in this position you
know I still get like I'm looking at my
name on the W championship and I'm still
just like wow this I can't believe this
has happened
but um yeah you just um you just you
just never know you know what I'm saying
you never know like how long it's gonna
last
the most important thing for me with
this title reign was making sure that it
was significant you know and taking on
guys like the Kevin Owens and Dolph
Ziggler's and Samoa Joe's and now Randy
Orton like Daniel Bryan and and making
sure that like this rain was a good a
great rain you know like I wanted it to
be like you know I don't I didn't want
it to just be somewhere I just show up
every week and have the title and like
don't defend it because what's the point
you know right why would we do that
so I just want to make that make this
one count you know because it's been
very serendipitous that I'm even here
right now if I didn't like if Ali
doesn't get hurt you know I don't get
put in that gauntlet match I don't get
put in the Elimination Chamber the fans
don't get to show the support and the
higher-ups don't get to see how much the
fans wanted this moment to happen and
then it probably doesn't happen I don't
even know if I'd be on the card if Ali
doesn't get hurt I wouldn't be on
WrestleMania we didn't have anything
going on right mean we probably have
been doing something maybe like a
backstage or something that you wouldn't
you would have forgotten about by now
but it's been really cool to have all of
these things happen
just serendipitously like going back to
Ghana with this title I hadn't been to
Ghana in 26 years and Sharif Rome yeah
yeah that's where I was born and you
know before that 26 years was when I was
born there so sorry I came to the
state's when I was like a year to Molech
so you know I've been in the States for
a very very long time
but I got to go back and forth gray to
meet like my fat my family is huge over
there so it was awesome to go back and
then again even awesomer to go back as W
each champion because and I say it all
the time like Kofi is a real unique name
over here but over in Ghana it's like
micro job yeah so to be able to go back
and show Ghani and children that the WWE
Championship has a popular ghanian name
on it like to see the motivation like to
see like the wheels turning in their
eyes like oh my god like anything is
possible like if Kofi can do this maybe
I can do whatever I want to do and like
to me get like emotional thinking about
it but it's like that's the most
important thing you know to be able to
provide motivation for people to go out
and follow their dreams and achieve
their dreams because it's the greatest
thing in the world man when you're
living out your childhood dream like
there literally is no better feeling man
like you feel like you're on top of the
world man like it's awesome so how big
was the reception for you when you went
over there I'm just so so crazy yeah and
we did a 24 documentary around the WB
network which you can still watch but as
amazing as the documentary was it didn't
even capture like half of the energy
that I felt when I was over there like
even at the airport like people there
was a big band everyone's like dancing
out there and like oh just just so
incredible we had I could not like like
when a big band shows up this is not the
WWE setting this up for you this is like
no the state is not for you did you know
that was gonna happen or absolutely not
Wow and I knew it was gonna be like a
good reception to me but even like
getting off the plane like everyone's
there like interviewing me I'm like oh
okay this is gonna be really cool and
then getting out there and then seeing
everybody just at the top of their lungs
and like yelling and and just a
lady to see me SWE champion was like so
humbling because at the end of the day
like I'm just a due to other curse to
follow his dream you know so like I'm
just a guy you know and like anybody
else so again like to be in that
position where I can like motivate
people and you know just to go out and
be the best versions of themselves like
that to me is what life is all about
going out in seizing life it's like when
we were kings when Ollie get off the
plane like yeah and for me got like
almost no reception at all we couldn't
go anywhere man we so I had like 10
security guards at all times they walk
in a circle holding each other's hands
and we went to my parents like home
villages you know where they grew up and
everybody just all everywhere we went
I'm just they couldn't get it and they
wanted to just like get a touch on me
and like just so so incredible to be to
be at the center of that security was it
wasn't to protect you from anything bad
it was just to kind of keep people from
so you could move yeah and that's all it
was everyone was like so so excited and
you know always obviously like
respectful to and just so happy to see
that like that joy in people's in
people's faces like to have that impact
on somebody's life as a human being
there's nothing better than that did you
have any idea how I mean you must have
known okay there's not that many people
globally famous at the top of their game
from Ghana yeah but did you were you
wear how well-liked you were and godlike
did you have any idea how big that
reception was gonna find my mom would
always say like yeah you know everyone
loves you over there and I'm thinking
like okay mom that's just her mom being
proud of her son but I had no idea was
gonna be nearly as big as as it was so
they declared this year as the year of
return where they invited members of
Ghanaian diaspora and African Diaspora
to come back to Ghana and get react
limited with their their roots you know
they invite everybody from everywhere
this year so this out of all the years
they could have declared that the
president declared it the year of the
return happens to be the year that I
wouldn't a WB championship it's it's
crazy like I said man just so
serendipitous for me to be in that
position and
yeah it was more than anything I could
have ever imagined it was just so
surreal and it feels like it was such a
long time ago but it was like just in
June right we've done so so much but
even still like talking about it I'm
still my mind is just blown like you
meet the president I did I made a
president more I met the the Ashanti
King was probably the most respected you
know individual in all of Ghana next to
the president or probably like on the
same level it it's crazy cuz I'm just a
dude man you know what I mean like I'm
just a guy so to be able to uh you know
and and and shake hands with the
president and then you know we gave him
like a replica title belt and to see
like the this excitement on his face
when he's got like at I was like a kid
in a candy store I'm like this is the
president of the country man and we're
just sitting here like talking like like
two dudes man it was awesome crazy crazy
and you grew up in Boston yeah after
yeah obviously Borden County then you
were so are you say about Antonio Brown
Oh see I wasn't gonna bring it up right
but you know since y'all I'm telling you
so it's almost like it's icing on a cake
it already has the best icing on it yeah
my kids so we go to this shop called
skull and cake bones and they have this
amazing of vegan cupcakes and
confectionery thing so they you know we
they're always excited about the
cupcakes but they just eat all the
frosting off you know right and I'm like
don't eat all the frosting but it's okay
if you eat all the frost because we got
this Antoniou Brown frosting right here
there's somebody promise that got
another cake it's incredible man it's
awesome man I can't so when all this was
happening with Antonio Brown over the
weekend I was at my parents house and my
sister's husband was there and he's from
Boston - yeah and so he's like a huge
Patriots fan and when he before he was
signed is a pic cuz it has all happened
over the course of like 30 minutes right
but like when he got released from the
Raiders he's going like well of course
they're gonna release him like this guy
has no idea what he's doing like he's
he's problematic cuz this is that and
then he goes to the Patriots he's like
you know I think he's gonna be a really
good addition I think if anybody can
handle it
this is gonna be great for everyone when
it's your team it doesn't I don't like
the guy but if he was gonna be a cowboy
I would take I wouldn't care the field
yeah and the thing about it too is that
like I mean who knows like what's real
and what's not
I'm really big in like not really
believing everything that we see because
people like to sensationalize everything
and you know especially 20-year guys
right well now that he's one of our but
you know New England is is classic we're
always known for giving people second
chances you know what I'm saying Randy
Moss same thing Oh Cory Dylan's at the
end of his rope he's never gonna be
anything you know what I'm saying so
like we have a habit of just like people
like to win you know so they come to New
England you know that want to win you
come into England that's all it is it's
football man so you believe in
conspiracy theories there's a lot of the
Antonio conspiracy theories about this
all being who's to say everyone people
call him like he's like oh he's a clown
he's out there clown and is he a clown
or is he a genius right you know is he
is he is he a genius his even pulling
Susie the puppet master you know that's
pulling all these strings and making it
an entertaining ride for everyone to
watch this all right increasing its
value increasing his value I still think
the Patriots made a mistake letting drew
bledsoe go one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the SiriusXM average